my kind of segment here one restaurant
shaking things up with new menu items
specifically to show support during
national pride month mikey beals from
shake shack is here with more on the
offerings and this all looks delicious
and i'm told that one of these shakes
will change my life
that's that's what i was told i i think
all three of them could change
potentially change your life but they
are some of the best shakes shake shack
has ever rolled out for sure i do want
to talk about the specific shakes but
why is it important to uh make a
contribution to the trevor project if
i'm not mistaken yeah so
during during the month of june it's
pride month um shake shack is is all
about that and so during the month of
june the proceeds from the sale of these
three shakes three percent of those
cells are going to go directly to the
trevor project trevor project's in a
it's a it's a non-profit organization
here in america that helps support
suicide awareness for lgbt
lgbtqia plus youth yeah um they sponsor
a toll-free number for for
monitored by councillors um to help
those youth
that is a youth group that is
particularly susceptible to suicide
ideolation and this is uh aimed toward
helping that and curbing that
that's wonderful all right let's talk
about the three we'll save the one that
apparently is going to change my life uh
for last let's talk about this one which
has churro and chocolate right yeah so
this is our chocolate churro shake so
it's cinnamon churro custard
and it has a spiced dark chocolate sauce
as well and then it's topped with
whipped cream and waffle cone cinnamon
crumbles on top
yeah and then we have our our
sprinkle cookie shake so it's a cookie
butter
custard that's spun with some rainbow
crispies and then it's topped with
whipped cream and rainbow sprinkles this
one premiered last month yep and this
one is brand new that one today and it's
called it's called what the sprinkle
cookie shake okay
comes a terrible noise
some i mean art shake shack
shake shack
sometimes it takes a minute to come up
for sure
it is
i'm a little distracted by my own
horrible noise but yes that is wonderful
yeah that's fantastic and now the life
changer i guess is the the oreo funnel
cake shake okay so it's oreo cookies
funnel cake crumbles um spun with with
vanilla custard
topped with whipped cream it's delicious
i might want to cut my mic for this just
in case because these are thick
i can't get any home i'm really afraid
to go at it this time
my life has changed that is really good
that's called what again the oreo funnel
cake shake i love that that is really
good it's fantastic um and then of
course all the other shakes if people
come in they can can they make a
contribution still even if they don't
order one
they can go to the trevor project.org
webpage and and make a donation there
but shake shack is just doing it through
through the sell of these three shakes
appreciate what shake shack is doing to
uh
celebrate and support the lg tv
community and um appreciate you being
here today yeah thanks for having us
this is good stuff yeah and not to
mention your fries and burgers which are
always outstanding yeah these are our
brand new bourbon bacon cheddar burger
and chicken sandwich um that just
premiered as well so come in and join us
in our sweeter together campaign good
stuff mikey thanks so much all right
rocky